[Musique]
jeudi le président de la république
assistera au gala de l'ouverture la
comédie-française fermé depuis deux ans
le théâtre français a été entièrement
rénovée du sol au plafond et si l'on va
continuer et joué les classiques molière
corneille racine
ce sera désormais avec l'aide de
l'ordinateur exceptionnel réuni pour à
deux les trois cyrano qui ont joué
devant 80000 spectateurs au palais des
congrès
dernières représentations buissonnière à
vendre est intégré les vieux murs tout
neuf de la rue richelieu les galeries
sont prêtes et les socles n'attendent
plus que le retour des statuts des
grands auteurs les derniers coups de
pinceaux et les interminables kilomètres
de moquer trop au même titre que ses
parfums ou sa haute couture la maison de
molière et l'inde et prestige de la
france
pourtant cette vaste entreprise
nationalisée n'emploie que 334 personnes
dont 84 comédien voici la nouvelle salle
les mauvaises places et le poulet y ont
été supprimés
il reste 8 192 fauteuils confortables
en ce qui concerne les acteurs il n'y a
pas de véritable problème parce que ils
retrouvent leurs scènes avec des
conditions je crois acoustique améliorée
mais en ce qui concerne le personnel
technique une partie du personnel
technique
celui qui plonge un peu plus que les
autres dans la technicité a certainement
des problèmes parce que nous avons un
jeu d'orgue extrêmement perfectionné un
jeu d'orgue à mémoire qui fonctionne
avec tonic mans et qu'il faut s'y
habituer mais des stages ont été faits
et depuis le 15 septembre
nous sommes tout de même sur la
manoeuvre terminées les commandes
manuelles aujourd'hui tout ou presque et
électroniques
ici le jeu d'orgue miniaturisés le
simple fait d'appuyer sur un bouton
permet sans éclairage instantanée
mémorisées dans une cassette que
l'ordinateur n'aura qu'à lire
autre avantage on pourra conserver les
cassettes et les réutiliser leurs
des reprises deux ou trois ans après
sans faire de nouveau appel au metteur
en scène je suis à la comédie française
depuis 26 ans et je ne pensais pas du
tout avoir l'électronique et la
télévision dans mon service
est ce que vous êtes habitué maintenant
cette nouvelle technique
oui maintenant nous avons les choses
prend mal commencé en juillet 74 sous la
direction de l'architecte en chef louis
blanchet les travaux ont duré deux ans
et coûté 6 milliards et demi de centimes
il était indispensable car les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient plus
respectées
le théâtre n'avait pas subi de
transformations depuis l' incendie de
1900 et cette rénovation a peut être
éviter une nouvelle catastrophe sans que
cesse pour autant l'activité de 5
nous avons réussi la fermeté syndicale
ce que ces travaux soient menés tout en
garantissant l'emploi et le niveau des
revenus
c'est une chose une deuxième chose qui
nous satisfait beaucoup moins et là je
parle en tant que membre du comité
d'entreprise
c'est que ces travaux ont été menés
d'une façon qui ne nous satisfait
beaucoup moins c'est à dire que au lieu
d'avoir été consultés régulièrement et
attentivement sur ses travaux en fait
nous avons été informés c'est franco
zeffirelli cinéaste prestigieux de roméo
et juliette qui met en scène lorraine
actions de la réouverture tout comme le
héros de musset il est lui aussi né à
florence mais ça ne les intéresse
bien équipé et qui de possibilités comme
il faut aujourd'hui que c'était un bon
théâtre aussi avancé mais stable je me
trouve chez moi comme si j'avais
toujours travaillé avec et c'était une
compagnie admirable des bons amis et des
grains g professionnaliste est-ce qu'il
faut être absolument florentin pour
mettre en scène lorenzaccio
c'est la récente réforme des statuts qui
a permis à claude ryf d'entre eux
français claude rich qui avait une
pierre dux comme professeur au
conservatoire a signé un contrat de
pensionnaires pour un an sur un trio
français comme stagiaire quand j'étais
élève au conservatoire il y avait un
temps j'ai j'ai eu un second prix je
n'ai pas été engagé et je suis engagé 20
ans après ça me rajeunit au
conservatoire était toujours fait par
des femmes
alors je ne m'étais jamais penchée sur
le rôle de lorenzaccio là
eh bien je découvre l'organisation comme
un élève du conservatoire et je trouve
ça passionnant
fiat s patience tout dire et ne rien
dire
[Musique]
habituée doucement l'imagination qui se
développe à donner des corps à ses
fantômes a touché ce qu'ils disent prêts
à mépriser ceux qui la protègent
cela va plus vite pour une passe de vrai
mérite et de frapper et le public
dépense-t-il de ce retour au bercail
cellule que le français le plus haut
d'un 10 de fréquentation et que pour
cyrano les 3700 places du palais des
congrès ont été à chaque fois prises
d'assaut même si avec la cotonne qu'à la
comédie comme chez elle parce qu'ici
c'est vraiment le nombre mais pas la
qualité
j'ai vu cyrano car une fois monsieur eh
bien c'est la seule fois où j'ai vu le
monde comme aujourd'hui vraiment
aujourd'hui c'était déplorant je prépare
la la comédie française rue richelieu
on fera soit un gage définitif parce
qu'il y aura beaucoup de choses à dire
sur la façon dont la comédie française
joue les pièces interprète des pièces et
surtout sur le fait que la commission
cet effet pour une edith un théâtre tout
neuf une réputation mondiale pierre duc
cependant est obsédé par l'amélioration
de l'image de marque de la comédie l'a
baptisé vieille dame le fait bondir tout
dépend de l'intonation avec laquelle on
le dit si on dit la vieille maison avec
tendresse je suis ravi mais quand on dit
vieille dans le sens de trop vieux et ça
arrive quelques fois quand je suis pas
content tout sera prêt le jeudi 4
novembre quand le président de la
république s'installera dans sa loge la
seule qui était été conservés quand le
rideau se lèvera une vénérable dame de
300 ans commencera une nouvelle carrière
[Musique]